hello everybody my name is Margaret
welcome to dance and to say something
[Music]
five things you would say on your
deathbed I wish I [ __ ] more I really
wish I bought a hot air balloon - I love
you
three I wish my parents love me more
good bye bye thanks thanks five things
five things you would say in the bedroom
[ __ ]
I'm ready where do I put it
[Laughter]
with your baby son your car [ __ ] rage
burn it
tell their effect to go suck a day
before be a guest on
with Jimmy Fallon five five days five
days five things five different please
but you have dyed your hair
sadly why Big Bob with blood - with
entrails three white with come fine
thanks I think sigh thanks I faced five
things five things you'd like to tell
your five five things you'd like to tell
Jeff it's possible I think she'd like to
tell Jeff my name is Jeff one hi your
name is terrible through your meme there
you're adopted
or your mother pays me to hang out with
you thanks five Biggs I think sighs
thanks five six five names were youtuber
for now oh do you monetize my eyeballs
sweet ad revenue
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't like spicy food pickup lines you
wouldn't use five different ways very
hardly fight things you would sell your
friends for okay [ __ ] concrete
five best bikes motor two three tires
floor working ah thanks all right thanks
Mike thanks I think spy Thanks five
things you would use shoelaces for other
than shoot straight away one time my
belt - I used to fish out a fish three
daunt people with it with a coin at the
end full use it to lure someone to their
death
but thanks five things five things you'd
bring with you the Barry Manilow
complete collection I think yeah okay oh
[ __ ] I wasn't recording alright so that
was five things thank you to all the
guys
[Laughter]
you know all these guys for helping out
if you want to see more of these funny
improv games and let us know in the
comments all right cool
Thanks
[Laughter]